[Music]
hi river babes
I'm your host Leon Aguilera and welcome
to our Sweetwater Secrets after-show for
episode 407 chapter 64 the ice storm
which was all about an icy Thanksgiving
in Riverdale and I am very thankful that
we had such a fun and great episode
don't get me wrong there was still
plenty of craziness but it felt like the
old Riverdale craziness that we all know
and love so I truly adored this hour and
it seemed like a lot of you were evasive
- we've got a great round of hisses and
kisses filled with your thoughts on the
episode so get pumped for that plus we
have an extra helping of romance to
discuss in seven seconds in heaven like
the facts bet FP and Alice kissed twice
but first let's gather round the table
and recap the biggest moments of the
week with the blue and gold breakdown
alright now first off let's talk about
my favorite storyline of the night Betty
and jugheads boarding-school slumber
party this story had everything bedroom
kisses how many kisses smoothing into
the past
junk food dinners and creepy people in
rabbit masks not to worry Betty was a
badass and unsurprisingly it was Brett
and Jonna masquerading in the halls of
Stonewall through a game of never have I
ever a bug head was determined to get
some answers about mr. chippings death
and one type in in a possibly fake
suicide note later Donna claimed that
she and mr. chipping weren't having an
affair and then told the headmaster but
like the good detectives that they are
Betty and Jughead aren't buying it mmm
next up let's switch over to thistle
house where things got well pretty much
as you'd expect as the ice storm
approached Sherrill was stoked because
it meant that she and Tony would be able
to toss your uncle's very dead body into
Sweetwater River but first they had to
deal with her nosy aunt so they invited
them over for a Thanksgiving meal and a
blossom family horror story courtesy of
Nana Rose apparently back in the days of
yore the blossoms used to eat each other
cuz of course they did so Cheryl told
her aunt and cousin that they were
actually eating the body of uncle
what's-his-name and apparently Cheryl
was lying and it was all just a big
distraction to get the uncles dead
the river after all it was all very Game
of Thrones but fingers crossed this is
the end of Cheryl and Tony being trapped
in thistle house please let them
interact with other characters as for
Archie and Veronica well Archie decided
he wanted to host Thanksgiving for all
the community center kids but now that
Hyrum is mayor he made SP be the one to
tell Archie that dinner was canceled as
you can imagine Veronica's not too happy
with her backstabbing family but they
decided to host Thanksgiving at the gym
after all and Dodgers family showed up
looking like a hot looking for a hot
plate of revenge but then they had a
really sweet moment and dedicated the
community center to Fred Andrews so much
happened you guys and I know a lot of
you are thinking yeah what about F bean
Alice don't you worry guys we're gonna
discuss their whole storyline in seven
seconds again Kevin yeah ladies and
gentlemen it finally happened FP and
Alice hey kis and ing twice and they had
a really sweet story line together so
while Betty and Jughead were away and
I'm assuming jellybean was with her mom
yeah Alice took advantage of their alone
time for a little smooching a dinner at
pops but when their Dumbledore when
their date turned into a double date
with Hyrum and Hermione thinks to have
turned for the violent as FP realized he
didn't want to be Hiram's henchmen again
by the end of the night Alice encouraged
FP to embrace his serpent roots guys
like finally if Alice kissed and that's
what a tongue twister right there and
then we were reminded that the serpents
are still a thing it was a Thanksgiving
Day miracle and another thing that I was
really excited about are all these other
little moments let's recap them right
now we had so many sweet bug head
smooches and we've got to just see Betty
and Jughead have some fun together and
just interact and then they're gonna
have to clean up that mess later but I
don't think they're gonna mind that was
weird though it was also really sweet to
see some barchi smooches they're always
so consistent and then Shoni come out on
the other side of the craziness shared
quite a cute lip lock and then there's
the doll
that damn doll ruined the kiss in my
personal opinion although it's very hard
to ruin a Shoni kiss
but speaking of litt let's move over to
hisses and kiss it shall we alright guys
well you had so many amazing tweets and
we're telling me all of your great
kisses and kisses so our first tweet is
coming from @p cookie and they said
kisses to all of these show me scenes I
hollered at the cousins reaction and
hisses to Brent
spying on bug head he sucks in every
possible way yes I love you I love you
too I love cookies that's nice let's
talk a little bit right now about that
camera scene that we saw at the end of
bug head hooking up I'm assuming yes
that Brett is the one that planted it
and first of all you secondly though
pending that they're both minors I don't
think that Brett will be able to use
that tape in any way because of the laws
out there and I'm just not gonna say
that word but you know what I'm talking
about so fingers crossed it doesn't
really turn into anything yes that was
very creepy check your rooms guys her
cameras if you're living in Riverdale
check your rooms for cameras yeah I
think we should do that but what I want
to talk about right now is a hisses to
Cheryl and don't get me wrong it was
hisses - the fact that Cheryl was so
keen on getting rid of her uncle's dead
body in Sweetwater River the very same
place where JJ's body was found in
season one yeah remember that it just
felt like that should have been a
trigger for her then again she currently
has Judy's body chillin in her house so
I don't even know what to think anymore
but that was something that just kind of
popped up into my mind it seemed like
that wouldn't be something that she'd
want to do but hey I don't know let's
take a look at what you guys are saying
right now on our live comments on
YouTube first up we have hisses - hiram
for being an ass and - Dodger into his
mom
oh we're gonna wait to say on that one
that's a tweet so sorry about that okay
we have Mary said hisses - Hiram just
cuz he's Hyrum yeah - Brett and Donna -
but kisses to the cute bug head barchi
and Shoni moments that we had very sweet
I loved all those Naomi says kisses -
Archie for talking so much about
dad it was so sweet I thought that was
absolutely fantastic I love that we keep
getting these great nods to Fred Andrews
throughout the season I think it's
absolutely incredible
it would be awful if we've just had that
first episode back and that whole
funeral and then didn't mention him
again so I love the fact that it truly
does feel like this is an homage to to
Fred and to Luke and to see Archie
dedicate that to him absolutely
incredible EPS plays said kisses to
Fallas and kisses to Cheryl and Tony
getting rid of aunt Crickett let's let's
talk about this we have so much to
discuss right now I want to lead it in
though right now with this tweet from oh
snap it's Mike because she wrote can I
just give a kiss to Tony for being like
the best girlfriend ever I would have
ran long ago but now that girl full-on
said Cheryl baby I got you when you
wheel out dessert on Jason's lap after
we make them think that we ate your
uncle like what but it was nuts in a way
that I could get behind it I don't know
I'm a big game of Thrones fan like I
said it was very Game of Thrones like
but I think that the weirdest part of
that storyline to me was the fact that
aunt cricket didn't really care that her
husband is dead
she just wanted people to think that she
didn't eat him it was very bizarre and
the fact that I just said that sentence
out loud was weird
also cousin fester sup dude like you're
traumatized for life
that was weird that was weird but a
weird I could get behind I don't know
maybe it's because all the characters
interacted more this week and that we
had them in pairs I don't know I just
like this episode so much more it was
weird but like this burger though like
it it was weird I can get behind
ok uni Karen eek said major kisses to
phallus finally oh it was so weird that
they kept showing them together and then
not kissing I don't know but I really
like the way that they played it out we
had some too sweet smooches a lot of
fans out there we're saying that they
were pissed that jelly
wasn't acknowledged I'm just going to
believe that she's off
it's Thanksgiving she's with Gladys they
should have made me thrown in a line
about that but that's just splitting
hairs at this point
Megan violet said kisses to all the
homage to Fred that is what Thanksgiving
is all about I completely agree with you
Juliet Hernandez said kisses to Mary
Andrews holding up that gun oh yes
Mary Andrews for the win that was a
great scene let's be honest this isn't
the first time there's been a gun on
Riverdale so I was not exceed that this
random family from Dodger just kind of
brought a gun and ruined Thanksgiving
however one of the things that I did
appreciate is that while Mary is holding
that gun she was using her like legal
expertise to explain that she has the
right to hold that gun and that they
need to get the hell out of there so I
don't know it just felt a bit more
grounded which is saying something but I
was all here for it it was great to be
able to see molly ringwald be able to
play that on the character can we also
talk about the fact that Veronica took
the carving fork and just jammed it into
that guy's hand that was pretty gory but
kind of epic like go Ronnie
and also like I felt badly when she
ruined dinner for her family but
whatever okay Tessa Tessa Wong says
unpopular opinion but I'm tired of only
seeing Tony and Cheryl together I wish
they would interact more with the others
not unpopular opinion Tessa I just said
the exact same thing please interact
with other characters well it's great I
think this is to make up for the fact
that Joanie was fighting so much last
season and so I get what the writers are
doing but let's get him out of this
house let's get him in some better
lighting I feel like the lighting last
night I kept seeing all these like sweet
scenes and as it are they kissing I'm
not quite sure and let's have them start
interacting because I think that Cheryl
being so isolated in Thistle house with
JJ is not good for anyone I want to
switch over to kiss it a little bit cuz
my kisses right now go to bug heads
story this week I thought it was so fun
and fresh and flirty and that Betty /
Lilly
was the MVP this week in terms of
amazing moments from hitting Bret over
the head to her delightfully random
excitement to live out her junk food
Thanksgiving dreams I was 100% here for
all of it I thought that we really got
to see fun stuff between them which
hasn't happened in a while and also like
just seeing Betty be Betty of course
she's really deep into the sleuthing
she's going to help jug find out what is
going on in this school but like just
the renown lines when she exclaimed like
yes I'm living out my Jughead dream or
junk food dreams I just rewatched that
so many times I thought it was great you
can just tell how much on and off spring
chemistry that of course Cole and Lilly
have together and I just think they were
fun that seems to watch so big fan over
here big fan and you guys all seem to
really enjoy it as well
Vivian cow said kisses to Veronica's
deep pockets for keeping the community
center afloat how we've talked about
this before how much money does that
girl have so much money can I have some
can we all have some she has so much
money like yes she's so generous with it
but someone needs to maybe it's me go
through all the episodes and kind of
estimate how much she has spent and just
add it all up cuz we know it was like
the 30 grand to Mary Andrews she did
that whole food Thanksgiving food was
not cheap you guys go Veronica I don't
know keep cooking those books girl all
right Keanu Stewart said I still feel
like Hermione is back together with
Hiram so that she can kick his butt once
and for all I feel like that too
but I also feel like we've seen that
storyline so many times but if it does
happen again I'm going to be really mad
just because we've literally seen
Hermione pretend to be in love with her
husband and then just try and kill him
like the whole situation I can't with
that family and like just because you
add a sister I'm still not a fan I'm
sure like I said almost I will do
something and I'll be like hey girl
you're not too bad no right now I'm
still just not a fan so buenas Dias my
love flamingos baby says kisses to
Veronica being Savage
and throw the food away and through the
food and his sister Brett how satisfying
was it when Betty smacked him on the
head with a golf club that was great
also Donna why are you always around go
away go go go go away we have a really
fun tweet right now from at bug head
dreamer and they said kisses to the
never have I ever game it was hilarious
how Brett and Donna reacted to Betty
being part of a gang and the fact that
she once kissed a girl I was really
surprised that they were like so
surprised by that like yes Betty is the
girl next door but like is a girl it's
fun do your thing
whatever you want to do everyone love is
love but yeah I just Brett and Donna
together I don't know if I trust her do
you trust her I think it was just a very
convenient story which is kind of rude
to be messing with a dead man's
reputation sorry mr. chipping
I still feel badly for you especially
because you just zoomed out of a window
so oh my best you into your family this
Thanksgiving they're probably so sad
okay Kenzi kool Moe said did anyone feel
like the deep-fried turkey exploding was
Fred's spirit protecting Archie and his
mother yes I did and I think that they
wanted us to think that because they had
that line from Mary it was very sweet
who deep fries their turkey I know that
people do do that tell me how it is in
the comments I'm curious to know Bret
Evans
kisses to Buckhead overload this week
it's about time
honestly I I never like to have it so
that we're like oh where is that like
it's we haven't had in forever
we had it it was awesome I just liked
that it was so natural and effortless it
wasn't like I feel badly because for
Varkey they just they'll have one kiss
per episode but they're not necessarily
having much evolution or a lot of like
fun like they're getting there one kiss
and it's sweet but I do feel like that
Betty and rughead had a bigger step
forward in their relationship you see
how protective they are of each other
and you see I just loved watching
jugheads face when Lily was putting the
stitches onto Brett and she's like well
then next time
my boyfriend like it's just fun little
interactions that are fun to look out
for that's just me
okay Nikki gueros says I love you or
Nica
sorry that's nice is that your only
comment okay Sara Windley says Hermosa
is suspicious to me I think that you are
picking up on the right threads there
because yeah she's suspicious everyone
think she's supposed to be also her
pearl necklace is so tight like oh go
longer set girl it looks like you need
to breathe a bit more okay Lauren
DiLaurentis blossom Pretty Little Liars
reference their hey girl can we please
talk about the promo for next episode
Cheryl crying at the end just broke my
heart I feel like the next episode is
going to be very cathartic and very
necessary for these characters we've
been talking so much about
Cheryl's mental health every single week
and I hope that this is the episode that
really kind of shows that it's so great
to take care of yourself your mental
health and to seek help when you need it
and I hope that they handle this episode
well fingers crossed we have one less
tweet they don't want to share for you
from at gummy bear pizza and they said
hashtag kisses to finally getting
phallus kisses to bug head during the
whole episode 2fp going back to the
serpent's yes and the show-me for
getting rid of the relatives hashtag
hisses - hi room for being an ass and a
Dodger and his mom being literally at
the same age both actors were born in
1981 gummy bear pizza I commend you for
your research I thought that she looked
a little young but the fact that you
went on the IMDB and checked out how old
the actors were is fantastic that
actress was fine I thought she was great
I still am a fan a penny pee buddy make
Dodger be penny Peabody's sister sorry I
just whispered that that would have been
awesome that was one thing yeah I just
um sure the whole Dodger storyline is my
least favorite that we've had of all of
season four but if we need Archie to
have an adversary and then to have them
all band together so that we can all
honor Fred in the end I'm cool with that
but me all right
just few more comments from you guys
Kayla Rose says kisses to this episode
the writers actually made me really
happy this week once again it is so
extremely difficult to be a writer of a
TV show especially a writer of a super
popular TV show and of course I've been
talking about in these weeks past that
these haven't been my favorite episodes
but we still need to commend the writers
for turning out this content and doing
such a fantastic job so seriously kudos
to the Riverdale writers but yes I will
say I'm so thankful that this episode
was so much fun because if I had had one
more episode in a row that I was not a
fan of I don't know what I was gonna do
Rebecca up said kisses to F P for just
mentioning the serpent's again hope to
see them soon did you guys see it looked
like he was wearing his serpent jacket
and the scene in the end where they were
all there I saw Reggie did anyone see
Kevin has anyone seen Kevin maybe Kevin
and Reggie should go on an adventure
together we'll be together edges
straight but like let him have some love
alright our last comment is coming from
coal ex Vina and they said kisses to FB
for being the best developed character
in the show and the Papa Bear moment we
got yes yes I think that FP it's nice to
see him have some screen time it's
really nice to be able to have them
really acknowledge the fact that he's
been Hiram's henchmen before he doesn't
want to do it again and I like the fact
that we're not going in circles with
this so how he's gonna be a serpent by
night and a sheriff by day I'm not quite
sure but I'm excited to see where it
leads us I'm also excited to see what
that means for FP analysis relationship
and thank you all so much for tuning in
I'll see you in two weeks
when Riverdale is back after the
Thanksgiving break for our Sweetwater
secrets after-show episode 408 chapter
65 in treatment which is sure to be an
interesting one but first you know what
to do give this video a like and then
hit the comments or tweet me your
thoughts about this icy episode which
storyline was your favorite of the night
do you think that Donna and mr. chipping
were really canoodling has anyone seen
Kevin and Reggie and do you think the
doll in Thistle house
to be gone by Christmas tell me and I'll
see you next time river babes